welcome back to CBS this morning
Saturday we have an update this morning
on a longtime CBS News investigation it
began more than two years ago when our
team found vulnerable drug addicts were
being paid to have experimental
surgeries and insurance companies were
being billed millions in the process
this month an extensive list of charges
was filed in a California courts and one
mother whose life was changed forever
told us she believes justice may finally
be served there's not a second of a day
that goes by I don't miss my boy but
it's you just learned we weren't given a
choice so we had to learn how to live
with it
Debbie berry spoke to us this week from
her home in Ashland Missouri he loved
football football was by far his
favorite sports two years after we first
spoke to her as part of our
investigation the district attorney for
Orange County California has filed 88
felony charges alleging a fraudulent
scheme at least 35 patients involved in
the scheme later died many by overdose
it was four years ago when berry first
got attacks from her son Brennan that no
mother wants to receive he texted me and
said that I'm a drug problem mom I I'm
in trouble
desperate to help bury God Brennan into
treatment in California one day called
her from a doctor's office to tell her
he found something to help he said I'm
gonna get an implant put in I'm here
with them and they've done a priest
certification that the insurance your
insurance will pay for it it was an L
trucks own implant a small pellet
inserted near a patient's abdomen it
releases medication to help curb
cravings and blocks the brains opiate
receptors so if Brennan used heroin he
conceivably wouldn't be able to feel the
effects he was so adamant about how much
it would help him did you know he was
getting paid for it I absolutely did not
know he was getting paid for it our
investigation found vulnerabilities like
Brennan berry were being paid hundreds
sometimes thousands of dollars in cash
to get this 30-minute outpatient
procedure you don't give a
addict cash money industry insiders told
us doctors made up to $30,000 in
insurance money for each simple surgery
and the money was so good
some doctors hired marketers and some of
those marketers hired recruiters who
lured vulnerable patients with cash as
part of our investigation we spoke
undercover with some of those marketers
and recruiters who pointed to a doctor
in Beverly Hills named Randy Rosen the
same doctor who did
Brennan buries implants excuse me dr.
Rosen two years ago Rosen declined our
request for an interview we've been
wanting to talk to you about why
patients are being paid to get surgeries
and said nothing to our producer outside
his office but now Rosen has been
charged with fraudulently billing
insurance companies over 650 million
dollars and stealing almost 52 million
dollars in what prosecutors say was an
elaborate scheme the district attorney
called Rosen a real-life Frankenstein
one of the many victims Brennan berry
who three months after getting his
procedure overdosed after taking heroin
mixed with fentanyl I came home found
I'm in his bedroom and he was cold and
when I got here after he died
Debbie berry learned her son was paid
$1,000 to get the knelt Rexona implant
she has been fighting to tell his story
ever since I'm doing this for my son I
think he would be proud that I'm doing
this I hope that he would be proud that
I'm doing this but I don't want he
didn't I don't want him to die in vain
we have a legitimate question sir what
if they get him convicted I've already
told the DA's office that I will fly to
California and I'll get on that stand
and I'll face that man look him right in
the eye and give a victim impact
statement I absolutely will do that you
think I'll get that chance I hope so I
hope so I want to face him I want to
face him and I want to tell him what
he's taking from me
and what I have to live with every day
for the rest of my life and what I'm
living without for the rest of my life
dr. Rosen pleaded not guilty to all
counts CBS News reached out to dr.
Rosen's attorney for comment multiple
times he has not responded to our
request we will continue to follow that
case as it develops